mais à quel moment vous êtes dans dans
la réalité française jamais en fait je
vais vous dire une chose je suis je me
sens plus japonais que
français alors Sébastien vous avez 22
ans hm hm vous êtes on l'a compris euh
célibataire vous vivez sans sans petit
ami vous occupez de jeux vidéo c'est
votre activité principale dans la vie
vous en gagnez de l'argent oui hein de
ça et en même temps on vient de le voir
donc c'est votre une véritable obsession
et donc votre ami la femme idéale c'est
cette ces jeunes filles que l'on voit
qui sont des jeunes filles japonaises la
jeune fille que vous aimez aujourd'hui à
travers l'écran vidéo qu'est-ce que vous
aimez d'abord son visage qui
est allié à ses cheveux que je trouve
d'une
originalité une originalité débordante
si je pe m m'exprimer ainsi et Alen
visage gay souriant bon quelquefois ça
peut ça peut se mettre en colère ou bien
faire une drôle de grimace dans
certaines situations mais c'est tout à
fait normal vous faites rire quand vous
dites ça parce queon dirait que vous
parlez d'une poupée une petite fille en
fait c'est ça je voudrais revenir à
votre écran vidéo puisque c'est votre
idéal de de femme de jeune fille quand
je vous demande de la décrire vous
parlez du visage des cheveux le corps
alors vous n'en parlez pas hein cor
m'ére nexiste pas le corps ne
m'intéresse pas quel est
qu'elle est une qu'elle soit plate comme
une limande ou qu'elle ait une forte
poitrine ça m'intéresse absolument pas
en fait ce n'est pas que la vidéo vous
n'êtes pas simplement il y a pas qu'une
obsession de la vidéo en fin de compte
si on é lgé vous êtes plutôt obsédé
entre guillemets vous sur tout ce qui
vient un peu du Japon non parce que
c'est la bande dessinée c'est la vidéo
en fait c'est l'image de cette jeune
fille japonaise qui vous obsè
complètement mais alors dans la vie
concrètement vous essayez de rencontrer
des des des jeunes filles japonaises
tout à fait ah oui tout à fait je et
pour ça je me promène be très souvent
euh dans le quartier de l'Opéra à Paris
car c'est là où se rassemble beaucoup de
Japonais c'est parce que c'est là où il
y a beaucoup de magasins euh quel
article que ce soit et euh voilà je je
trouve un peu mon hiver il y a des
restaurants japonais où on mange des
soupes une sorte de de de grands bol
avec des nouilles dedans avec quelques
viande avec quelques quelques légumes
comme je vois dans certains dessins
animés japonais et j'ai voulu faire
l'expérience et voilà je suis un un
consommateur de de restaurant japonais
et alors parfois est-ce que vous
déjeunez vous dînz avec certaines jeunes
filles que vous rencontrez vous faites
des rencontres elles sont à l'image par
que euh il faut aborder il ne faut pas
aborder la femme japonaise comme on peut
faire avec une femme française parce que
les les les ah bon vous allez nous
expliquer comment alors et comment vous
avez appris et bien je dirais
que avec une femme française enfin une
jeune fille française
euh ce serait
euh une discussion euh disons ordinaire
banale mais avec une femme japonaise qui
est pourtant le même âge que moi ce
serait plus avec du vousouvoimement mais
alors une jeune fille que vous ne
connaissez pas que vous rencontrez à
l'Opéra ce que vous dites donc d'abord
lui dites-vous hm hm et alors ça ça va
être quoi vous allez l'inviter à
déjeuner vous allez lui parler de quoi h
en fait je ne cherche même pas séduire
je ne cherche même pas séduire
c'est-à-dire
que en fait c'est mon comportement
disons naturel je je suis naturel avec
elle je ne cherche pas à l'aborder pour
avoir une moindre relation c'est c'est
la pureté
l'authenticité le naturel on doit vous
pensez que c'est comme ça que vous allez
qu'un jour vous allez rencontrer votre
princesse charmante et que ça va se
faire comme ça c'est sû c'est sûr que
avec cette démarche ce sera ça peut être
très long alors est-ce que ça veut dire
qu' a 22 ans vous n'avez jamais eu de
relation
amoureuse jamais jamais jamais embrasser
une fille de ma vie ah embrasser jamais
même pas embrasser m pas même pas mais
par exemple les jeunes filles j'essaie
de comprendre les jeunes filles
japonaises qui vous font rêver sur votre
écran vidéo lorsque vous en rencontrez
une est-ce que vous n'avez pas eu envie
de lui prendre la main d'avoir un geste
de un geste de tendresse euh aussi bien
sûr bah par exemple avec les deux jeunes
japonaises qui sont venus au mois d'août
dernier mais c'est au ça s'est fait vers
le 13e ou 14e jour mais parce que on
qu'est-ce qui s'est fait on fait si vous
voulez on on fêtait on fêtait avec des
amis donc on était un petit peu joyeux
puis on s'était pris la main et puis on
marchait main dans la main voilà mais
c'était pas
pour parce que on est attiré l'un de
l'autre tu avis amené les photos heinoui
j'aiené des photosé des photos photos en
dessous là vous dit absolument qu'on les
qu'on les voit ils sont des visages très
rieurs très souriants de un peu de
petite fille vous vous avez l'air alors
j'étais aux anges je vous fais pas
dire donc j'ai j'ai le sentiment moi un
peu en vous écoutant qu'à force de je la
Redonne
voilà qu'à force de de jouer à ces jeux
peu à peu vous vous déconnectez
complètement de la réalité que cette
jeune fille que vous recherchez bah vous
ne la rencontrerez
jamais je schématise mais bon disons que
bon il est vrai que si on reste enfermé
tout le temps à ces jeux vidéos c'est
sûr qu'on on ne la rencontrera jamais
mais combien d'heures par jour vous
passez devant les vidéos ou à lire enfin
vous êtes immergé dans cet univers
japonais combien d'heures par jour
je ne pense je je pense au Japon plus ou
indirectement ou
indirectement depuis le réveil jusqu'au
coucher ah carrément carrément mais à
quel moment vous êtes dans dans la
réalité française jamais en fait en fait
vous vivez entre deux mondes
le pour moi je me sens je je vais vous
dire une chose je suis je me sens plus
japonais que français j'avais peur que
vous me disiez ça vous n'alz pas me dire
ça quand même c'est pas vrai
att pour moi la la la France n'est plus
un un pays où quoi que ce soit
m'intéresse on dira un vieux monsieur on
dirait tout à quou un vieux monsieur qui
a perdu ses repères et tout avant même
de commencer à naître c'est vrai c'est
vrai et au Japon alors vous vous c'est
votre rêve d'y aller d'aller j' vais le
1er janvier
prochain c'est votre plus grand rêve
j'imagine ah oui tout à fait vous allez
peut-être être déçu ça va peut-être op
bien d'ailleurs d'être confronté à la
réalité ça vous allez peutêtre marier ah
çaag compte bien ah oui çaag compte
trouver concrètement ma future femme
disons je le disais en plaisantant mais
c'est sérieux alors c'est sérieux et
c'est pour ça
que avec la la femme
occidentale je suis complèteement j'ai
décidé de la bannière de de ma tête
maintenant quand je vois une jeune fille
France
surtout américaines alors les
Américaines je ne peux pas les voir
parce que ell elles sont beaucoup trop
belles et elle profitent de leur beauté
pour pour
être mécréante avec les autres oh là là
oh là là comme vous y allez mais je vais
vous dire une chose qui peut surprendre
c'est que quand je vois par exemple une
superbe jeune fille du style Claudia
chiffer c'est-à-dire BL trop sophistiqué
pour vous ah je l'aime pas du tout ah
bah oui j'étais me pas du toutur par
quandme et même à croire que le diable
m'en veut une fois j'ai oui le diable
m'en veut parce qu'une fois j'étais dans
un restaurant et elle est venue
s'asseoir juste à côté de ma table sans
que sans quelle horreur dire qu'il y a
tellement d'hommes qui en rêv c'est
justement à vous que ça arrive une
histoire pareil c'est monstrueux flute
alors elle était avec David Copperfield
moi j'étais en train de de manger et
puis elle elle arrive tranquillement
puis elle se met juste à côté de ma
table alors j'étais vraiment je non
c'est pas vrai non pitié tout m pas ça
dramatique cétait dramatique quelle
expérience sauvage et ravageuse tout à
fait bon et bien si je prends une femme
donc
physiquement au niveau du visage comme
Claudia
chiffer ça me laissera froid je peux
vous dire que même si c'est un très beau
corps par que regarde en premier les
hommes ordinaire parce que bon
maintenant il est clair que je ne suis
pas
ordinaire vous ne vous ressentez pas
comme quel quelqu'un d'ordinaire
ben moi je je vis je vis pour moi je vis
normalement vous avez un lien fort avec
votre mère ah oui oui oui oui c'est
est-ce que c'est d'une certaine manière
aussi une femme idéale votre
mère euh est- quene pe remplacer c'est
pour pour le cas de ma mère oui personne
ne peux la remplacer oui parce que c'est
ça ça avec elle que j'ai de temps en
temps une part de
tendresse la seule tendresse que vous
ayez c'est avec elle les moment
tendresse pour l'instant quand on
regarde la
télévision c'est c'est les petits câlins
très gentils quoi ah oui il est temps
que ça peut-être de de passer à autre
chose maintenant maintenant c'est
beaucoup plus rare à mon âge un peu
d'espace donc oui oui mais c'est
nécessaire ça vous vous en rendez compte
Sébastien être nécessaire de couper ce
li ou oui bien sûr bien sûr bien
sûr mais maintenant ant je voudrais
partager ce que j'ai toujours fait
jusqu'à présent avec ma mère avec une
jeune femme et en l'occurrence japonaise
quoi qu'il arrive c'est la définition
même de l'obsession quand même on croit
que finalement autre chose c'est
japonais alors je sais pas ce qu'il faut
vous souhaiter je sais pas si vous il
faut vous souhaiter bonne chance pour
trouver cette femme japonaise en janvier
ou s'il faut vous dire on espère que
vous changiez
d'objet pas pas de fixation ça c'est
c'est clair ça c'est
clair pour ne rien manquer sur ma chaîne
in mireum abonnez-vous et activez la
[Musique]
cloche